okay babies it's your bus psychobabble
and we're going back in at Pontiac
office so my heart's ready to blow of
course okay get your we're back in here
I can and cannot thing in here I don't
know why something about the like
turning makes me like SEC like it much
Ziegler or something no no why I don't
know why and I don't K I think yeah
let's see any what new scares are rabble
in here something really irks me about
how I can't like Run has crying cut that
out and that's that no I did that stop
that stop that man it's Rick and dark
dad okay I check and dark oh my god
and someone keeps playing all that music
how is that here at night playing that
music
and then our supposed to be that clothes
after dark what's going on here that's
the real [ __ ] there's no parks in Iraq
you know well I don't hello sir I just
doing some gardening at night that's
nice because they don't have the hot
sunlight on your back and I blame him
everything out right here nope I hope
this is it like a rinse and repeat like
okay I found a padlock I'm gonna collect
ten miles to get something done I gotta
go it is that nice is that him
why shouldn't I bear house they chanted
out was he thinking there's the king and
it's that there's a ducky can I go over
here ours and now it's time to go back
hey that's a stereo that's been playing
all this medic right yeah well I guess
I'm gone back down I got the king now
it's time for me I got to that padlock
ever you know what I'm saying
okay Bebe's okay yeah what's gonna
happen now I'm at the bridge again way
too quiet why is there quiet what's
gonna happen oh they snap all lace oh my
god I just jumped I don't like that
who's crying
I think he's crying again what the heck
it was a way to hide and get in there
and get in there
can you stop crime get a job
house crying in here so I like this but
I'm gonna cop I with him I guess
and there's all that nice certificate at
that place of death for have caused that
strangulation and slight seven Oh what
this is gonna be scary I don't know what
I'm doing here what golly crap laws that
where's the phone
that it what's that down all over there
and the things getting scared then uh
he's Harry Hayes back oh no no I don't
like this now and that was spending way
loved that that's a scariest thing if
specially if you're a Mac user okay oh
my god oh my god oh my god
theater talented can't Farrakhan it's
the character chaired the only think
it's trust me he's a shadowy shape with
shellfish appears and drawings by
character for comic nothing dangerous
that's such you say and it's sound that
guy I guess crime saying no no I can't
outweigh right but oh that thing the
night of night let's chant the dark
darkness has not overcome it okay if you
want to say that that's fine I guess
that's in here
how missing feos where's the fierce I
don't know if I like this game very much
because of how scary it is
get out of here rats get out of here
that's out right here what is that a
pillow I'm gonna find somebody
because the farmers are so big they're
just like freaking slow to walk on okay
got up-down and inwards what are these
birds what is with this kind birds there
we go how do I change this there's
always a wrong but how do I change him I
guess I got to get like a Piper's I let
that dead mouse how did I what that such
a thing was that well it's getting very
scary but I'll do it
Ty's does now this is not gonna make out
what's how about here it's too bright
you cheatin method visual stimuli trance
oh it's white dead quiet
oh my god no he's very well as usual
let's go the essence of our case you
remember that we had a similar case okay
who is this guy can you still hear me
you know me with this a little bit so
this thing should be fall on my face
there we go
it's always when you're back jack it's
always the back Jack it's all scary okay
you know what I mean I get these are off
but it was someone really needs that
three go upstairs really I don't know if
I like this game Jessa is too scary for
me I'm not used to something like this
oh my god what's going on
this is too scary test Garrett urban
farm a do I hear something that Joker
seller PI yeah yes oh my goodness
holy cannoli what is that noise oh my
god what is that
no they got me what did I fail
okay looks like I got that one second I
fall can I not come in here
I brought it for it a writer for it yeah
yeah get away they keep getting me down
here
okay the only way I can I can go is like
that
how's that how is that is they're gonna
ranch or something because I feel like I
gotta turn those knobs okay get a
headache for all this okay is that a
ranch or something so stupid bars
everywhere what is that huh what is that
shout out and pee I just chained because
what's that right here some pipes
yeah they you see pipes right there god
oh god I've gotta throw I know this is
where it goes so I get asked and that
these go out these go in now folks I
does it and this goes out
my god how do I go what's gonna happen
now this is nothing but triggers nothing
but checkers I kept turning lights
whenever we can go through that now is
it lit up
I always lit up all right wow it's just
a bad room this is the bedroom all right
what's that bar doing there
I thought a 40 I'm always afraid
something we're not coming home what
what am I gonna lead upward from there's
a TV
mmm-hmm now you and my brother had this
guy nice guy whatever this is great I'm
a big I came but this is the part where
I get scared because looks like we've
done everything in this house the only
left is to go back I can't belong
all right here we go here is that
triggers there's the triggers got got I
think it was out here Yeah right now
here we go
all right is that yeah is that you're
adding alright I guess I'll I'm not up
ass out there
Dax Iwatani oh thank you